I remember going through this awakening
of strong black empowerment and identity
and it was brought on by the music I was
listening to in the conversations I was
having with other black students in
college and it was like I was coming out
of this shell that I've been in for so
long I grew up in mostly white
neighborhoods went to mostly white
schools and I heard a lot of racist
comments growing up and for the longest
time I wouldn't say anything I would
just let it boil inside of me so I
traveled to Africa went to Kenya and I
met another college student and I
remember proudly telling him that I'm
African American and he looked at me and
he was kind of laughing and he said
there's nothing African about you he
said I didn't have any connection to the
culture and that he didn't understand
why black people in America identified
themselves as African so now I was
finally feeling strong enough and wise
enough and old enough to defend my
identity but I wasn't African enough to
be African American